dans les bras de gladys une buse royal
âgé de 10 ans elle souffre d'irritation
aux pattes nécessitant des bandages et
une surveillance toutes les trois
semaines ans masc il ya de l'oxygène qui
arrive avec un gaz anesthésique on va
voir filer au fur et à mesure qu'elles
respirent finalement de plus en plus
elle va tranquilliser jusqu'à s'endormir
complètement
l'animal est ensuite intubé et
monitoring pour surveiller sa
respiration je vais mettre un petit j'ai
lé protecteur dans les yeux pour éviter
de la sécheresse parce qu'elle peut pas
cligner des yeux première étape la prise
de son là on écarte les plumes le
vaisseau qu'on va vouloir voir c'est la
jugulaire qui est ici
petite fille aux bleus on va ponctionner
deuxième étape de scanner
on arrive au niveau du coeur ont un
petit peu les poumons
maintenant on arrive le foie qui va
apparaître petit tube digestif et les
reins qui sont ici c'est mon produira
pouvoir leur transférer dans la salle de
soins
tout est normal hormis les bobos sur ses
pattes c'est plutôt pas trop mal est
légèrement un beau tissu rose et qui a
comblé aussi il y avait un trou ans qui
avait été mis en avant la greffe ça va
quand même pas mal pas mal combler la
croûte si on est un petit peu ça un peu
trop ça a tendance à saigner donc on va
encore là laissez donc nous on va faire
on va bien nettoyé et on veut pas qu'ils
aient de deux bactéries qui vient de se
produire ferrée au niveau de ce tissu
qui ralentirait encore là la
cicatrisation donc un petit peu de
bétadine la bétadine savons là on va
leur faire des petits bandage pour
protéger les lésions au niveau des pieds
avec ses petits ronds de coton on va
aller déplacer le concept va mettre son
poids au niveau de son pied on va les
déplacés l'appui pour pâques et d'appui
au niveau des croûtes pour pas que ce
soit un désagréable pour elle et puis
aussi pour ça permettre de d'avoir une
guérison plus rapide
après plus d'une heure elle reprend ses
esprits tout doucement